foreign
[Music]
networking demo Series in today's video
we'll be covering the topic of
cross-cloud interconnect my name is
Ahmed and I'm a developer relations
engineer and I'm super excited to be
bringing this video to you if you're
ready to dive in let's get started
in a previous video we saw an overview
of cloud interconnect we introduced the
new cross Cloud interconnect service and
we saw a configuration demo
quick recap cross-code interconnect is
part of the cloud interconnect family
which is comprised of dedicated and
partner interconnects
cross Cloud interconnect is perfect for
multi-cloud strategies and allows you to
configure high-speed dedicated
connections directly from Google Cloud
to the other Cloud providers today I'm
super excited to be introducing you to
networking specialist Nick who will take
you through another crossbar
interconnect demo this time between
Google cloud and AWS
let's hand it over to Nick thanks Ahmed
in this demo we're going to establish a
cross-cloud interconnect connection
between Google cloud and another cloud
provider for this example the other
cloud provider is going to be AWS
now I'm going to have to select a common
location for which to establish the
cross-cloud interconnect connection and
in this case for this example the
location is going to be Madrid
now in this demo I'm going to show how
easy it is to provision and establish
the cross-cloud interconnect connection
using our console now with that let's
jump right into the demo
now in the console under hybrid
connectivity I selected the interconnect
tab now as you can see we can see three
different types of interconnect I will
select the cross Cloud interconnect
connection and click continue next I'm
going to order a new cross-cloud
interconnect
I'm going to give it a name
next I'm going to select the remote
cloud provider as AWS
I'm going to select a remote location
and as I mentioned for this demo the
location is AWS ITC M2 in Madrid
next I'm going to select the same
location for Google cloud and for this
demo I'm going to select the capacity as
10 gigs next I'm going to select the
Redundant interconnect connection and as
you can see all of the populated
information is already there
finally I'm going to enter my contact
information which I will receive any
subsequent communication for this order
then I can click place order and click
submit to submit the order
now that the order has been submitted
you can see here both order numbers and
telling us what to do next
now I'm going to jump over to the AWS
console and create a lag for this
connection now I'm going to request a
new connection I can name this similar
to the other name I gave in gcp
the location I'm going to select the
same location Madrid
ITC M2
for Port speed this needs to match to be
the same as 10 gigabits and for the
number of connections since I only
created a single 10 gig connection on
the other side I'm going to select one
connection
next I'm going to uncheck the connect
through an AWS Direct Connect partner
and I don't need to make any other
settings so I can create click lag
next I'm going to create a second lag
which will represent the secondary
connection that I've created on the gcp
side so we can give it a similar name
we'll select the exact same location
Port speed of 10 gigs and enter 1 as a
new connection uncheck the connect 3 AWS
connect partner
and then create lag
now you can see I have both of these
connections pending
now wait until the connections become
down and then I can download the Loa
now I click the download Loa button
now under the service provider I give
the name Google cloud and then I click
download
now for this example I'm only going to
do this once for one port
but you would have to repeat the same
process for the secondary Port that
you've created
now as you can see here I go into my
email and I've received an email
describing what to do next
and here I have to attach the Loa that
I've just downloaded from the AWS side
so that we may configure and provision
the cross Cloud interconnect connection
I've attached the Loa and click Send
now we wait and then the connection is
going to be provision in the background
now as you can see I have my connection
up on the gcp side I have that
connection for the ITC M2 circuit and I
can see here some details about the
light levels and the dmarc if I jump
into the AWS side I can see the
connections up
I have a 10 gig port and I can see some
traffic being sent through already
and with that it's that easy to
provision and configure a cross-cloud
interconnect connection thank you very
much
to learn more about cross Cloud
interconnect please read the
documentation and check out the links in
the description see you in the cloud
foreign